Emperor Akihito is the current Emperor
of Japan and has been since 1989 when he
succeeded his father now 82 and having
suffered ill health there have been
reports circulating that he wishes to
abdicate in his second ever televised
address to the nation yesterday a kajita
suggested that he no longer felt able to
continue in his Rome to his for ability
as a result of his deteriorating health
whereas in Britain the Queen can
advocate at her time purchasing in Japan
there is no such thing Empress cannot
abdicate they're supposed to rule until
they die there's no law in place hold us
to happen and that means that if you
were to abdicate they would have to vote
for you vote three new doors in
Parliament because the emperor is not
allowed to express political views
he can't specifically say on Sat
because that suggests there should be a
constitutional change there are a few
options there
the emperor is very well revered in the
country he's very well respected and
public opinion seems to be that at age
82 he should be allowed to live his
final years in peace however there is
the likely opposition from politicians
and the right to this he will not want
to change traditional laws this means
that what might happen as though the
Regency where he will have reduced room
and then his sons will take on more
responsibilities until he dies and his
eldest son succeeds
you